that want to hold the system accountable
at the same people that would rather
save seats
to make sure that republicans don't take
it
so like many people here i'm sick and
tired
of black people
having black people come to when you
want votes but when we come to you to
pass accountability bills
or to hold the justice system
accountable you do not
open your door so why is it that we
continuously
open our doors for you so we're asking
president biden because we have lost
faith in tim wells
he's the same individual that just
yesterday introduced a 9
million dollars at the minnesota senate
to bring more cops from outside
jurisdictions
to our state that will not be held
accountable
and he has yet to say anything about
police accountability bills
so we're asking we're asking president
biden
and kamala harris and tim walls to do
your job
because tim walls tim walls is right we
are
in a state of emergency because black
people are dying
and under his leadership many black
people have died
so he's got murder on his hands so it's
time you do your job and hold this
system accountable
because we know it works for you when
it's time to hold the black officer
accountable
so do your job
quickly before we take questions i'd
like to invite chelsea to do a quick
piece
of spoken word
hello everyone uh well i was just down
here to listen i felt it on my heart i
do spoken word to read this piece that i
wrote a couple days ago
all right it's called dante right
we're tired of getting killed we're
tired of having to heal
in my city one officer's trial is not
even over before 12 recklessly pulling
their steel
women behind that badge there's many
cowards in disguise over stepping their
stand
using their uniform to casually inflict
their racist malice hate
is too many officers okay with being our
ending fate
by our i mean black people because
they've been killing us compared to
white people at an astronomically higher
rate
pride too high to see when they're wrong
you're a 26 year veteran man you knew
what was going on
after all these years really accidental
discharge or your firearm
you thought it was a taser even though
you clustered from your dominant side
you can't stay they waited saying we all
know that's a lie
why don't you tell the truth officer
potter your nerves got the best of you
while attempting to arrest an unarmed
black man
easier to shoot instead of putting your
gun down where you stand
if you can't take the heat get the hell
out the kitchen if you're scared of the
assailant let becca finish that mission
and fear for your life is different than
someone unarmed resisting a rest in
broad daylight
people mad they tear in the city up we
mad 12 steady
steady sending our people up so many to
name
this ain't right but this one i wrote
for you say his name
dante wright
in president obviously
they ran on reform rather than that sort
of transformative change they do all the
commissioning
my question for you all is i guess why
do you have faith to work out bringing
in the federal government
based on what we have heard from them on
the campaign
the first problem is they haven't even
started with reform
let alone transformation and we don't
have faith in them
but we do have a duty to hold them
accountable
for what they ran on they came and
knocked on the door of the black
community to get
elected and now it's time to pay the
price for our votes
we are not like some of the black
politicians that are happy
sitting around a table with them we are
demanding
justice and they can appease those
people
but they still have the answer to the
black community at large
we are the ones who are suffering under
the weight of oppression
and we expect them to live up to their
responsibilities
as the leaders of the free world
the democrats have no more excuses this
isn't just about biden and harris
they control all the three houses and so
if they fail
it's the democratic party that continued
to fail
and in this time they have no
republicans to blame that's right
that's right any other question
hi um i'm judas from the shavers i
am wondering what
you guys think so basically black voters
are kind of like
it's not a catch-22 there's a situation
where
you feel like voting for democrats kind
of like the lesser of two evils
and that's kind of been held over ahead
for a really long time especially we saw
in 2020 with trump versus biden
so moving forward in 2024
do you guys think that black people
should withhold their vote from the
democratic party regardless of who
is running against joe biden
so first of all the democratic party and
the republican party
sadly are the same the republican party
freed the slaves so-called so
we know for sure that both parties have
historically failed
communities of color one party likes to
be right next to us
another party likes to stand next to the
police with their dogs
but the reality is that this country
is built on the backs of black people
indigenous people
and this country has failed the
the native american people and black
people for so long
so i think it might be the right time
for
poor people in this country black people
in this country and many folks who are
tired of the broken political system
to maybe create an independent party
that will bring forth
the people's party that will bring forth
but right now
the democratic party until 2022
is on the clock we will see what they do
and after that
i think people are no longer going back
we are
going forward and that may mean without
both of these parties that's right i
just want to add to that a little bit
because i i do agree with my brother but
i also think that
um we have to start grooming and running
people for office
um it's not enough to just
vote for folk who just come up and say
they're running for office but
who do we want in office how do we groom
them
and how do we prepare them to be in
office so that we are supporting folk
who have our best interests at heart uh
it doesn't matter whether you democrat
or republican neither party has served
us well
you know but if we have the right people
running
and if we're putting our support behind
the right people
then we have a better chance of
transforming systems
one of the things that i also want to
say is that it's more than just voting
it's holding people accountable once
they get into office
we have a habit of voting people in and
then we don't hold them accountable
when they get to office and we have to
show up we have to show up at the
meetings
we have to show up at the hearings and
we have to show up before
they already have the plan in place so
that we have
input from the beginning not not after
the
train has already left the station and
now we're trying to
catch up and so i i think that you ask a
good question
i think it's a question that we're going
to have to really deeply think about
but i also think that we have
to prepare people and groom people to
run for office
and put people in office who have our
best interests at heart
and who can transform systems
and i want to um add on to what jelani
was saying
because the thing is like you're saying
that um we
it does feel like the black community
votes for the democrats a lot because
it's the list of two evils
but in reality they're the same party
systemic um oppression that we see in
america
can that type of oppression can only be
held over us
if both parties was complicit
so that's what we need to understand the
democrats and the republicans what we're
talking about
is the difference between someone going
up there like trump insane
um painting all mexicans as rapists and
and murderers and the difference between
that and then someone
like biden who is part of administration
at the highest deportation rate
of all time with obama that's the
difference they're doing the same thing
but some people say it out loud and some
people
say kind words and say they care when in
reality with their policies they don't
that's why we need a new party that's
why we need
a revolutionary party and a party for
the people
because right now the democrats
republicans the only thing that they're
doing
is they're trying to benefit themselves
and their pockets
and protect their property and that's
not what we need
we need what the people need
i just want to give a quick fact check
on black people vote for the democrats
right
black people this last election and the
elections previously
have actually voted not to vote
voted not to vote more than they have
voted for any person or party
there are a number of reasons for that
and then there are actually
a lot of black people who their vote was
suppressed
so let's think about this this is the
system of government we currently have
if we're going to have a new party we
are allowed to
if we want to stand up in a hearing we
are allowed to
if we want to be in the streets
protesting
we are allowed to
so when we are talking about what our
rights are
these are rights that the constitution
validates
but these are rights that are inherent
to us being on this land as people
so let's stand by that you do not have
to be 18 to reach out to your
representative
you do not have to be documented to be
in the streets
and to be a person for change and to say
what is right
you do not have to be registered to vote
to see the change in our policies
and so that's what we're calling for
even when we're talking about this mass
incarceration system
they strip our rights to vote
and they making decisions about
prisoners and prisoners are not at the
table
and then we see prisoners dying
and we see prisoners being tortured even
in coven 19 we see prisoners being
isolated and being silenced while
they're getting coveted and they're
thinking
everybody got covered in here i'm a doc
and so where is their voice who
are we to not listen to them that's
right
because this country the foundation of
the values of this country is built upon
freedom of speech
upon freedom
i mean i'm going to say it again so
what's free
is there any other questions
my name is jonathan mcclellan and i was
uh i was a
national delegate for the dfl party and
i lightened and kimball harris to know
that if you think
that your lack of action is not
affecting the delegates
who helped get you into office
i was bernie sanders national delegate
um but
after you took it we helped you get into
office
if you don't think that we're shook and
we're
asking where you are
wait till 2024
was there another question
i'll ask one more if nobody else has
anything um
obviously you all have mentioned some
specific changes you all want made
appealing 1033 i heard qualified
immunity i heard
uh while you all have national media the
president's ear is there anything in
particular maybe a top three the kinds
of things that you want
all want done immediately what are the
kinds of things
uh that you all want to see done
immediately as you all mentioned and
kind of bring that change
uh that makes that has an effect right
now
i'll give one and other people please
chime in
we need to end the war on drugs
immediately
and we need to release those folks who
are incarcerated
solely on drug related crimes from
prison
because we have demonized black and
latino men
in this country for many years because
of a connection to the war on drugs
and now that marijuana and other drugs
are legal
in other parts of this country white men
are able to profit
become multi-millionaires and there is
no demonization and no incarceration
that is not right for that to happen in
that way
that is something that joe biden and
kamala harris could
work to do immediately because
they are also responsible for many of
the drug war prisoners who are
incarcerated
and we want to send a message to those
who are incarcerated
that we have not forgotten about you we
stand in solidarity with you
and we will continue fighting for you
um we put together our collective of
organizations put together some
legislation
i'm here stayed in minnesota that we're
advancing right now
that are that is sitting on on uh empty
desks
um number one removing the statue of
limitations on wrongful
death house file 717 prohibiting
qualified immunity for law enforcement
house file 1104
releasing body camera footage within 48
hours house file 1103
and the no knock warrants house file
1762
ending police only responses the mental
health calls
house file 1686 police professional
liability insurance
house file 440 ending prosecution for
reporting
police misconduct house file 2201
civilian oversight strengthen house file
640.
we also support the harddale sheryl act
of 2021
and the philando castile omnibus bill i
have one question real quick
one more so the third one is we need the
federal government to reopen
and open uh all of the investigations of
officer-involved shootings that have
been put on hold during the trump
administration
immediately we also want
president biden to immediately usher a
task force
using the depart the department of
justice and other departments
to bring that law into every city with
when an officer-involved shooting
happens and we want to see that in the
state of minnesota
we know that there are three candidates
right now to be the next u.s attorney
and one of them
has lost the faith in this community
andrew luber we don't want him back
and we need to make sure that if he
brings someone like that back there will
be consequences for his
his party so i think that's another
pointer and for him
who supports him
people
so i was one of the 646 people arrested
uh the charges have still not been
dismissed against us
we know that governor hawkes is using
his leverage
in supporting the city of minneapolis
and bringing in a militarized police
force
to keep those charges intact it's a
waste of time energy and resources
to keep those charges hanging over our
heads we're encouraging
all 646 people if they are able to do so
it's not legal advice
but if they're able to do so to fight
their charges
and as far as people being arrested as
far as we understand we have jail
support
that has been happening through the
national lawyers guild and the legal
rights center
and people are typically being released
within 36 hours
of being detained any other questions
all right well we want to thank you all
for taking the time to be here with us
you see that
we have some very serious concerns about
what's happening in the state of
minnesota
the black community is not safe we have
been neglected
and we are using our voices to demand
that joe biden
and kamala harris take action thank you
thank you
everyone